Lube yourself up and prepare to go fetus
fishing because we have an all-new
episode of Watchmen and yes we now
actually have the specs for dr.
Manhattan's giant [ __ ] in this video
we'll be going over the latest episode
and you're gonna want to stick around
for the whole thing because I have some
new theories on everything from Will and
Lady trues relationship Cal's connection
to dr. Manhattan and even lube man the
first image we get of the episode is of
an egg here at Clarke acres farm in art
eggs are often used to symbolize
fertility and the cycle of life the
Clarks owning an egg farm and receiving
a child
Kalen Angela cooking with eggs when Cal
gives a speech about the cycle of life
and even Ozymandias is egg shaped fetus
transformer all reinforced the theme
that life is a cycle the egg business
isn't going so well for the Clarks as
cars past Katie Clark who reads a book
called fog dancing fog dancing is a
novel in the Watchmen universe created
by Max Shaye who is one of several
artists invited by Ozymandias to create
the alien squid creature that would
wreak havoc on New York Katy dropping
the eggs here is symbolic of both their
business failing and the end of their
legacy of their own cycle of life as
we'll later find out from true they've
tried to have children but Katie's eggs
were not viable their legacy ends with
them lady true wants their land all 40
acres of it and in return she offers the
one thing they've never been able to
have their own child oh and five million
dollars there's not a lot we know about
true other than she's a Vietnamese
businesswoman who made her trillions in
Advanced pharmaceuticals and biomedical
tech she purchased adrian veidt's
companies after his mysterious
disappearance and as i'll get into later
in the video the connection to him runs
much deeper I also got huge Superman
vibes here first this couples last name
is Clark just like Clark Kent they live
on a rural farm can't have children and
an unknown object later comes crashing
on their property a property now owned
by Lady true-true was expecting this
object hence why she gave the Clarks
three minutes to sign the papers over so
that whatever crashed would be on her
property and belonged to her true
somehow knows the future and I guess
we'd all be trillionaire
- if we had that ability but back to
this comet what is it
one theory is that whatever is in there
contains the DNA of dr. Manhattan it
could be a baby or something entirely
new that dr. Manhattan has created at
the end of the graphic novel Manhattan
talks about using his time to create a
life form of his own we also know
throughs company runs those telephone
booths where you can send messages to
dr. Manhattan who is currently on Mars
if true can't communicate with Manhattan
they are likely in league to create a
new race of humans we already know true
has the ability to create babies that
share the DNA of their parents and now
with these pills memories and
experiences can be shared - could this
not mean you could create an exact
replica of a person we'll get more into
this later on especially it relates to
beyond who I actually think is Lady
shrews mother in clone form the title of
the episode if you don't like my story
write your own is a quote from chin
watch Abe a the author of Things Fall
Apart the same book how is reading near
the end of the episode in it the main
character commits suicide by hanging
himself coincidence that Judd was also
found hung back at Angela's bakery
Angela gets rid of any evidence
surrounding her grandfather will wiping
everything down and dismantling the
wheelchair into a duffel bag
Lori Blake is hot on her trail having
found the wheelchair tracks at judge
murder scene last episode Angela will
later suit up and throw the duffel bag
into a garbage truck when she finds out
she's being watched by Lube man my best
guess as to Lubin's identity is that
he's PD he's tall and lanky and has a
vast knowledge of superheroes and we
know he likes to put on masks him
knowing this knowledge about Angela also
provides the most conflict for her and
the story four episodes ahead Angela
breaks into the Greenwood cultural
center after being notified that a new
match has appeared in her family tree
it's here she learns about her
great-grandparents the same people we
saw in Episode one trying to escape the
Tulsa massacre interesting to note here
that the voice-over says young will was
killed in the attack but later on in the
episode Laurie says the fingerprints of
a man going by William Reeves was found
in her car a man who was a cop in the
40s and 50s in New York City but fell
off the grid Reeves is also the last
name of Chris
Toofer reeves the actor who first
portrayed Superman something about will
doesn't add up and it's likely
time-travel has something to do with it
Angela here's her car crash from the sky
the same car that almost struck glory at
the end of last episode at home Angela
sleeps in Topher's bunk bed where they
have a heart-to-heart about being scared
after all Topher just saw a man Shawn
the head notice his stuffed animal which
is a recreation of adrian veidt's
genetically altered lynx Bubastis the
next morning we have cows somewhat
nonchalant talk about heaven being
pretend and it's here I want to talk
about another theory that Cal is dr.
Manhattan or at least some form of him
there are several compelling arguments
to support this one we already know from
will in Episode two that Manhattan can
change his appearance to cow's demeanor
is similar to Manhattan's very calm and
plain spoken like how he just tells the
kids that heaven isn't real or isn't
fazed by Angela when she wants to start
a fight Cal is from Vietnam and we know
Manhattan has a history there Laurie has
mentioned Cal being attractive in every
scene she's in with Angela and we all
know the history Laurie has with
Manhattan during the white night Cal
also looks at the clock almost as if
he's anticipating it we also never find
out how Angela survived that attack it's
possible that Cal as Manhattan vaporized
him the name Cal is also very close to
Cal L Superman's birth name then near
the end of the episode
Angela mentions Cal having been in some
sort of accident if he was ever in the
hospital it could mean true industries
may have access to his DNA and we know
that will in true are in league with one
another and that will has planned
something that will betray her my guess
is that this betrayal has something to
do with Cal perhaps the real cow was
switched with this new Manhattan hybrid
and memories restored using these pills
it's a little far-fetched but half the
fun of the show is examining all the
cool possibilities angela visits Looking
Glass in his underground bunker where
he's been taking photos of the squid
that rained down from the sky
he believes they're from another
dimension Angela asked him to have his
ex to examine the pills since she
doesn't want them being examined at the
precinct and having Lori know about it
she even hands him Judds KKK robes at
the precinct Senator Kean junior thinks
Angela who is dressed as sister night
saving him at the funeral service he
knows her identity my guess is that
Senator Kean is one of these 7th Calvary
and these attacks are planned to paint
him as a hero in order to get him
elected the fallen car is referred to by
Lori as a thermodynamic miracle which
she says is the scientific term for it's
all connected and like the puzzle the
Clarkes were putting together at the
beginning so - are we figuring out how
everything in this show is connected the
agents believe that whatever moved that
car had to have come from these large
air drones found constructing the
millennium clock which we'll get to in a
second there's also an interesting
discussion of why vigilantes wear mass
not to protect their identities but to
hide the pain of a past trauma Lori
became Silk Spectre to hide the trauma
of her abusive father Edward Blake aka
the comedian and how he sexually
assaulted her mother the original Silk
Spectre the agents arrived at the
Millennium clock which is currently
under construction what exactly it's for
is unknown but my best guess is it's
some sort of time machine or dimension
teleporter vn refers to it as the first
wonder of the new world and that unlike
the ancient wonders it will be built to
last fun tidbit the true logo looks a
lot like Tesla's true greets Lori and
Angela and her vivarium which is heated
to mimic the climate of Vietnam the N
hands them a list of employees who would
have had access to those drones the
night of the crashing car in Vietnamese
truus Angela if she got wills pills
but Angela responds tell him he can ask
me himself inside is also a gold statue
of Ozymandias which she looks upon with
reverence
notice how true refers to him in the
first tense why'd you have them make him
sole Oh
because he is old she knows he's still
alive luckily because she was the one
who put him in a very among now last
episode i theorize manhattan was behind
Ozzy's imprisonment but it's looking way
more that it is lady true mainly in part
to the baby clones which we'll get to in
a bit she is building off his ideas
leading me to believe they once worked
together and that she imprisoned him
when her plan was revealed hear me out
on this theory
Ozymandias in the graphic novel is the
main antagonist unleashing a giant squid
that killed millions in New York tube
and humanity together against a common
threat it's the old do a little bad for
the greater good argument I believe in
the show he'll turn out to be one of the
good guys fighting against true who
wants to turn people into genetically
altered dr. Manhattan's I mean if
everyone is blue and had Manhattan's
powers there would be no war no racism
trues parents likely died in the Vietnam
War and Will's parents died at the Tulsa
massacre so they would have motivations
for doing what they're doing
Ozymandias who hated dr. Manhattan
likely found out about this plan hence
his imprisonment and true taking over
his company using his inventions to
become a trillionaire her latest project
the Millennium Clock is likely
Ozymandias invention as well not hers
true is the new Ozymandias essentially
banishing him away just like how
Ozymandias was able to banish manhattan
to mars and now to the man of the hour
Ozzie picking up these little fetuses
and lobster traps notice how he's
looking for ones that aren't deformed
like the one here whose arms are missing
he brings them to his lab where he puts
them in a giant microwave which turns
them into full-fledged adults they have
no memories at all
essentially blank canvases which would
be great if they could take a pill and
be infused with memories no back at the
castle we see that it is the day after
his fourth anniversary judging by the
candles on the cake here he has killed
all his staff likely because it has been
for years and his escape plans have not
been going as planned as i theorize
before each one of these scenes from
episode 1 to 4 that feature
Ozymandias take place a year apart from
one another we know Ozymandias
disappeared in 2012 meaning
if Aussie storyline were to line up with
the main events of the show it won't be
until his seventh year or 2019 true
tells will they are three days away from
their big plan and guess what three more
episodes from now will be Episode seven
or as we know seven years my guess is
that something big will happen to line
up these timelines Ozzy catapults the
dead bodies and they disappear through
the clouds but something is off here the
clouds almost seem to be projected as
the body goes through it we know from
last episode that the bodies come back
completely frozen leading me to believe
that whatever is outside this dome he's
in is either space the Arctic where Ozzy
had previously made the Varian's or
someplace with an exceptionally high
altitude I leaned towards space since
we've seen Ozzy supply oxygen to his
poor test dummies
vn wakes up from a nightmare and we see
her hooked up to an IV machine she tells
her mother about it how men came into
her village and burned it forced her to
walk she can still feel the burning on
her feet we learned that true is giving
BN pills designed for her to experience
memories hence her nightmare which is
likely a real memory of her
grandmother's we know from the beginning
scene with the Clarkes that true can
create biological copies of children
with DNA is it not possible that BN
could be a clone of her mother which she
is now infusing with these memories I
mean look at these old lady glasses true
his concern that will is getting cold
feet and going back on his end of the
deal but he reassures her that's not the
case what this deal is is one of the
newer mysteries introduced to the show
but as Laurie said it's all connected
we'll set in motion a plan that will
betray his granddaughter a plan that
true says is three days away watchmen
has been really good at subverting our
expectations but as for now I think will
and lady Tru have teamed up to create
some new race perhaps with the help of
dr. Manhattan for the betterment of
mankind but all these theories are for
fun and I'll probably all get shaken up
next episode so I want you to leave your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below make sure to smash that like
button and stay tuned for more water
videos you can also find me on Twitter
at things story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much